welcome back to a Fandango studios I'm
Kristian harloff and I'm Tiffany Smith
and we've had some awesome guests with
us here so far at San Diego comic-con
right now we are lucky enough to be
joined by the director of the upcoming
animated movie Kubo and the two strings
thank you so much Travis Knight for
coming to chat with us absolutely my
pleasure to be here all right Travis so
this is a really epic movie what were
some of the biggest challenges for you
making this film well we work primarily
in stop-motion our the way we make our
films is a combination of art craft
science and technology but the
foundation is stop-motion which is a
technique that's been around for a
hundred years since the dawn of cinema
so when we started making this film it
was this big sprawling epic fantasy and
it kind of flies in the face of what you
can typically do in our medium we
essentially shoot this film on these
these gussied up tabletops in the middle
of a warehouse and it has to look like a
large-scale epic and so that was you
know right right away that was a
challenge to make it look and feel like
a big fantastic epic but we have these
incredible massive monsters in the film
that our heroes have to come up against
it's in a lot of ways it's a nod to the
classic Ray Harryhausen Creature
Features yeah
and our biggest one is when fully
assembled it's 16 feet tall it's massive
with this 23 foot wingspan so making
these things look and feel real and give
it the size and the scale that we needed
that was a real challenge I mean what
was that like for you getting to finally
see some of these characters come to
life on the set even though you're
saying you know it's in a warehouse on a
tabletop but something like that where I
think I know which villain you're
talking about or which thing they go up
against right
he's a bag of bones that one but what
was that like getting to finally see
that and the motion and the action on
set you know it's a weird it's an oddly
moving experience which sounds weird you
start developing these projects yes
emotionally moving as well but you start
developing these projects and it takes
years and years we've been working on
Kubo for five years now yeah and so the
first couple of years it's just
developing the story the characters
finding the world and then you start
designing them and then slowly bringing
them to life
so when you see them on a set something
that began is just an idea and now is a
fully realized thing that is being
brought to life a frame at a time by
animator it's kind of as close to magic
is that anything I can imagine to see
these things come to life it's really a
beautiful thing
well you mentioned that it's 55 years to
do and this is your first time as doing
a feature that's director right what's
the difference between directing this
feature and from being a lead animator
well it's considerably different as an
animator you are focused on minutiae
you're focused on the granularity of
bringing something to life a frame at a
time you're really focus or focus on
details which you are as a director as
well but as a director you've
essentially become the nexus of every
key creative and technical and artistic
decision so you know all these all these
decisions ultimately land on your
shoulders and it's really it's in some
level it's very very exhausting just all
the different things that you're
involved but it's also really
exhilarating because you're you know
you're interacting with these incredible
passionate brilliant artists who are
really inspiring I mean you try to
inspire them but they are the ones that
were inspiring you it's an amazing
beautiful collaboration I'm incredibly
grateful for it it's it's the most
meaningful creative thing that I've been
involved on entire life I'm just talking
about collaboration
obviously for an animated film you've
got to have great voice actors involved
and you had some pretty big-name actors
from yet George Takei Charlize Theron
Rooney Mara Matthew McConaughey yeah
what is it like for you getting to
direct them and work with them on this
project it's intimidating particular
first time director yeah I mean
everybody in the film virtually has you
know a trophy case full of Oscars and
BAFTAs and SAG Awards and every
recognition you can imagine these are
some of the finest actors in the entire
world and so but it's also exciting it's
a testament to I think that the quality
of the project that actors of this
caliber were drawn to this material they
really fell in love with the material
and the story and so you know it's a
really great collaboration actors work a
lot differently than animators do so
that was a big switch in my head to kind
of figure out how each group would work
and how to best direct them but
ultimately they gave incredible
beautiful moving performances and I
think you'll see in the film who was the
most intimidating everything you were
intimidated I'm like call it out who was
it well you'd have to say Charlize
Theron she's a she's a goddess yeah it
that the I mean that she's been blessed
with so many gifts she's funny
incredibly smart beautiful obviously and
so talented it's a little unfair for the
rest
if someone was given so many gifts but
you know I guess we all have our cross
to bear
at least you turned her into an animal
for a little when people think of an
ill-tempered flea-ridden primate I don't
think they necessarily think of Charlize
Theron yes she does it you know that she
can do it you guys sure um you know I
want to go back to something you said
earlier about the detail that you put in
this movie there's so much detail in
every single frame of this movie is
there something for you that you're
gonna find kind of satisfying that
audiences might miss the first time and
I have to kind of go back and and see
again like that's how much detail is oh
I mean there I mean there's so many
different things it's you know we we we
kind of bring these props to life and
there are all kinds of knowledge to the
artists that bring them to life but just
in terms of the signage or just a little
props and stuff in past films that we've
done you know they'll put like the art
directors name they'll put it on like a
sign somewhere and so there's little
little tiny nods throughout the film
that are that are acknowledgment that
the people actually brought these things
to life but no I mean this thing was
brought to life a framed of time and you
know there's thousands upon thousands of
frames so there's all kinds of tiny
details that will be rewarded on a
second viewing well what I love so much
about this one too is there's so many
themes that the movie encompasses even
just from a coming-of-age story to
connection with your family to how you
deal with losing a loved one what is the
thing that you really hope that fans
walk away with after seeing it well I
think that that basically gets to the
core of it I mean the film does explore
that time in our lives when we begin
that shift to become adults that we
cross that Rubicon from childhood to
adulthood but it also looks at it from a
parental angle because you know I went
through that experience like we all have
going from a kid to being an adult and
it's it's an experience that's fraught
with a lot of different emotions and
challenges as we're exploring the world
and figuring out what kind of people we
want to be but as a parent you know now
I have I have two teenage kids and and
to see them go through that same
experience it gives you a different
perspective on it and so the film kind
of examines that time in our lives from
both perspectives from being a kid and
being a parent of a kid going through
those those life changes and it's a
really beautiful moving film you know
what else is moving the music yeah and
as a director as far as choosing the
music what was the process like as far
as the score and going through
everything you know this is the tone and
this is the music that I want to
represent this my feeling good it's an
their character and yeah it really is
well Kubo is basically he's like an
oarfish figure a music is an important
part of his life he's a musician so
that's how he brings this these these
characters to life that's his magic
that's his gift and so when we started
work started to look with for our
composer we needed someone who could you
know have god-like musical gifts which
is no small task but we'd previously in
our last film box rolls we'd work with
Dario Mari Nellie this extinct
extraordinary musician and composer and
so we started talking to him and he was
excited by the idea of trying to define
that fusion of east and west of old and
new of the real and the imagined and so
we started talking through the big
themes the big ideas in the film and he
did an incredible job I think it's just
this beautiful combination of Eastern
instrumentation and scales along with
kind of these more romantic instruments
that we tend to associate with places
like Italy and it's that fusion of those
things with this modern cinematic
Western point of view on this this
beautiful world and it's something we've
never experienced before it really does
get to the emotion of the movie well I
have to ask too because origami and
paper folding is such a big part of the
movie as well and you have to build out
a lot of that stuff did you learn to do
a lot more origami I mean it takes years
and years to become a great organist so
I think I'm certainly not that skilled I
think we all had to learn just enough so
we knew what we were doing and there
were definitely people on the on the
crew that are great at it but I
certainly have an appreciation for I
think when you think of origami it's a
lot like being an animator you're taking
this inanimate thing and you're through
transformation you're bringing it to
life changing it into something else so
in that way I kind of tapped into that
aspect of Who I am because I'm an
animator as well well what I wanted to
ask you we were we were blessed here in
the Fandango studios today we have some
butts from the the movie can you tell us
a little bit about what we have in the
studio time right so those are our three
heroes we have Kubo who's the central
figure in the film and then we have his
two animal compatriots which is you know
monkeys she's this savage sword wielding
snow monkey brought to life by Charlize
Theron right and then we have Beetle
who's a big brawny oversized man bug and
he's a beetle samurai something you
don't see every day but he's pretty
great as well that's great thank you for
letting us we've been admiring those all
day thank you so much for having us
they're little works of art they are
the grass is there any particular ones
or models or anything that you kept from
this film trick that you're always gonna
be like this was from my first time
director no I have not yet but there's
the I think there might be a couple
things that somehow get secret away in
the studio
well I wanted to thank you today for
joining us one of the things that we
also wanted to present you with was is
yeah we're very excited for comic-con
and the gifts things should they open it
yeah please yeah go for it
and you guys all watching make sure you
stick with Fandango because we've got so
much more good stuff coming straight out
of San Diego from comic-con in the
fandango's studios and check it out
everywhere on all platforms of social
media for freeeee and dango that's how
you find everything that we're doing
travis once again thank you for joining
us thank you